اقتحمت مجموعه من المستوطنين باحات المسجد
الاقصى المبارك صباح اليوم تحت حمايه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وذلك تلبيه لدعواته
جماعات الهيكل المتطرفه وتقدم
عضو كنيس السابق مجموعه المستوطنين خلال
اقتحامهم باحات المسجد الاقصى
وكانت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه قد حذرت
من مخاطر دعوات منظمات يهوديه متطرفه الى
تنفيذ اقتحامات واسعه للمسجد الاقصى اليوم
الثلاثاء ويوم غد الاربعاء واضافت الوزاره
الاقتحامات الاستفزازيه للاقصى في ظل
حكومه اسرائيليه متطرفه تهدد بانفجار عارم
لا تحمد عقباه في ساحه الصراع وطلبت بتدخل
دولي عاجل لوقف استهداف المسجد الاقصى
وتحميل الحكومه الاسرائيليه المسؤوله
المسؤوليه
الى ذلك اقتحم عشرات المستوطنين بلده حوار
جنوبنا الليله الماضيه وذلك تحت حمايه جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شهود عيان قالوا ان
المستوطنين اطلقوا الرصاصه الحيه في
الهواء والقى والحجاره على سيارته
الفلسطينيين على الطريق الرئيسي للبلده
بينما اطلقت قوات الاحتلال وابلا من قنابل
الصوت والغاز تجاه سكان البلده الذين
احتشدوا لصد الاقتحام وافاد مراسل الجزيره
ان شبان الفلسطينيين اصيبوا بحالات اختناق
جراء قنابل الغاز
الى ذلك هدمت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تسعه منازل سكنيه بزعم بنائها دون ترخيص
في القرص الشرقيه والخليل واريحا في الضفه
الغربيه في الوقت نفسه طلب وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي لتامر
باستمرار هدم منازل الفلسطينيين في القدس
حتى خلال شهر رمضان المبارك
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه دانت باشد العبارات
تصريحات وقلت الوزاره في بياننا هذه
التصريحات من شانها اشعال مزيد من الحرائق
في ساحه الصراع خصوصا انها تندرج في
اطارما تتعرض له القدس من عمليات تهويد
وحملت الوزاره الحكومه الاسرائيليه برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو حملتها المسؤوليه الكامله
والمباشره عن جرائم الاحتلال وانتهاكاته
المتواصله في القدس
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني افاد باعتقال
القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثمانيه
فلسطينيين على الاقل وذلك في انحاء
المتفرقه منظفه الغربيه نادي الاسير قال
ان حمله الاعتقالات جرت في بلده طقوع جنوب
شرقي مدينه بيت لحم وفي ضاحيه السلام في
القدس المحتله وقد جرى احاله المعتقلين
للتحقيق
للمتابعه ينضم اليها من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره سمير ابو شماله مرحبا سمير انقل
لنا
ابعاد هذا التصعيد المتصاعد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله
نعم محمد يعني نبدا بما يعرف بحمله كاسر
الامواج التي بدات في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتل منذ نحو عام وهي التي تختص
بحمله الاعتقالات في عديد المناطق في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله جيش
الاحتلال وايضا شرطه الاحتلال قاما بشن
عمليات اعتقال في تركزت في بلده تقوع جنوب
شرقيه مدينه بيت لحم وايضا في ضاحيه
السلام الواقعه بين مخيم شعفاط وبلده
عناتا شرقيه مدينه القدس المحتله حيث تم
اعتقال ثمانيه فلسطينيين على الاقل تم
نقلهم الى مراكز التوقيف للتحقيق معهم
بقضايا وملفات تتعلق بمقاومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه هذا من جانب من جانب اخر كذا
هناك اقتحام صباح هذا اليوم بعشرات من
المستوطنين في بلده حارس كيف الحارس في
قضاء محافظه
ايضا اعمل او اداء رقصات
واداء الصلوات في تلك
الساحات وذلك باحتفالا بعيد ما يعرف بعيد
المساخر او البريم وايضا هذه
المجموعات من المستوطنين قامت بعمليات
الرقص في هذه الساحات واقتحام البلده
بذريعه ان هناك مقامات تعود لعدد من رجال
الدين اليهود حسب المعتقدات الدينيه
اليهوديه وذلك بحمايه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وانسحبوا من القريه على في
ساعتنا يوم امس كان هناك ايضا اقتحام
عشرات المستوطنين وذلك في بلده حوار
جنوبيه مدينه نابلس حيث كان هناك اداء
للرقاصات وسماع الموسيقى بشكل صاخب بين
منازل المواطنين وتحديدا على الشارع
الرئيسي لبلده حوارهم وكان هناك ايضا
اعتداء على مجموعه من الفلسطينيين بينهم
عائله فلسطينيه كانت تستقل المركبه وبعد
انقضت حاجتها من داخل احدى المحل التجاريه
وكانت تتحرك للمغادره ولكن
المساطرون رشقوهم بالحجاره واظن ايضا
راسهم بغاز الى عصابه عدد منهم
وايضا بالاعتداء بالضرب ورشق بالحجاره كل
هذه التطورات وهذه التصعيد من قبل
المستوطنين جاء بحمايه جيش الاحتلال في
بلده حوار التي شهدت قبل نحو اسبوع
اعتداءات بالحرائق واصابات بالمئات من قبل
المستوطنين والجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
البلده سنعود اليك بالتاكيد خلال مواعيدنا
الاخباريه المقبله لمتابعه ابعاد وتبعات
هذا التصعيد المستمر شكرا جزيلا لك سمير
ابو شمالي من رام الله